TIM ANDERSON: Hi, and welcome
to Tech Tips from Teachers.
This episode will focus on
programming and coding apps.
Our guest today is Sam Patterson
from Palo Alto, California.
Sam holds an educational
doctorate in literacy,
and is currently an elementary
school technology integration
specialist.
Prior to that, he
spent 11 years teaching
middle and high school, and is
also an educational blogger.
Sam, what sort of impact
have you seen technology
have on the classroom?
SAM PATTERSON: In
my career, I've
seen technology have a
truly democratic impact.
At the beginning,
I was the only one
who could bring content
into my classroom.
So no matter how much I wanted
my students to have choice,
I always had control.
Now my students can choose what
content they're learning about
and bring it in on
their own devices.
TIM ANDERSON: And then with
coding and programming,
those are two words that we're
hearing more and more and more.
What sort of impact have
you seen that content have,
and what should we expect in
the next five or 10 years?
SAM PATTERSON: I
think we're just
at the beginning of
what we're going to see.
We're going to see a lot more
content integration, where
students are going to be not
programming for programming's
sake, but programming about
what they're learning.
I have students now
who are using Scratch
to model the
behavior of molecules
in different states of matter.
It's amazing.
TIM ANDERSON: We've
heard from teachers
that there are few important
elements for coding
and programming apps.
It's crucial for these apps to
have opportunities for students
to apply the content that's
been presented to them,
it's important that there are
engaging incentives, and also
an opportunity for
students and users
to interact with a
larger community.
Sam, why is it so
important there
are opportunities for
application within these apps?
SAM PATTERSON: We want
coding apps to give students
the opportunity to
turn on the camera
and take a picture of
the learning they're
doing in class, and
bring that into the app,
so that they can
then use the app
to show what they understand
about that knowledge
and build more of an
understanding about it.
TIM ANDERSON: You've
got experience
with students of all ages.
Why are incentives so important?
SAM PATTERSON: Because
we want the students
to be able to be motivated
to work independently
through the challenges
in the programs.
Because all of these do have
challenges built into them.
TIM ANDERSON: Got it.
And then what about
that community piece?
Why is that important?
SAM PATTERSON: It's
huge, because when
the student publishes
their work to a community
and other students
can interact with it,
they really are
publishing their work.
In the classic
model of assessment,
that publication-- sharing
it with the world--
is kind of the highest
level of the work we do.
They've created a text.
They've sent it
out into the world.
And it's really
motivating for students
when they realize other
people are playing their game,
watching their presentation.
TIM ANDERSON: Let's take a
look at some exemplar apps
for coding and programming.
First one, what makes
Tynker for School so great?
SAM PATTERSON: I love
Tynker for Schools,
because they have
deep resources.
I can tell my students, if
you don't know the answer,
read the screen and find it.
And they can find either
the directions or the tab
for help that brings
them those directions.
This is important
because teachers
can't be the ones holding all
the knowledge about coding.
The application needs
to give students
the guidance and assistance
they need, when they need it.
TIM ANDERSON: And what do you
like about The Foos Free Code
Hour.
SAM PATTERSON: The
Foos is very engaging.
My students would spend all
day there if they could.
And it's engaging
because it's playful,
there's really good incentives,
and at the same time,
they do a good roll out
of different abilities.
And then at the
end, students are
able to choose what they want
to do with their abilities.
So if they want to create
an infinite number of boxes,
they can.
TIM ANDERSON: And
then with Pocket Code,
what makes that such a
great app for classroom use?
SAM PATTERSON:
Pocket Code allows
students to program something
on their Android tablet,
and then publish
it to a community.
And other people--
students and non-students--
will be able to
interact with that code.
And that gives
students a real sense
of having created an
actual text that's
going out into the world.
TIM ANDERSON: So to
recap, a few key things
to keep in mind
when developing apps
for coding and programming.
It's crucial for students
to have opportunities
to apply what they've learned.
It's important for apps to
have engaging incentives.
And it's important
for users to be
able to interact with
a larger community.
For more episodes of
Tech Tips from Teachers,
check out the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]